there can be a lot of mental baggage  around making decisions so I asked a  World Poker Champion his method for  making decisions Under Pressure so we  have this concept called expected value  on average what is the expected outcome  from doing this and so the way they  calculated is for each instance it's the  how good it is multiplied by what  percentage it is happening so I say like  flipping a coin right 50 chance of heads  are just a chance of Tails it evens out  I'm going to pay you two dollars if it's  heads and you're going to pay me one  dollars if it Tails okay two times fifty  percent is one plus one times fifty  percent is 50. so every time we do this  I bet a dollar expect to make a dollar  fifty so I'm making 50 cents every time  we do it every action that we take has  an expected value you have some form of  risk and some form of reward the way  that my brain works through just getting  punched in the face so many times and  poker is just like is the risk worth  reward